so a lot of folks are familiar with
government doing things like building
roads and bridges or providing schooling
or Parks or at the federal level
National programs or say the military
and the natural question is how does the
government pay for all of this and the
simple answer is it's primarily through
taxes there's other sources of revenue
as well but we're thinking on a local
level taxes are things like sales tax
you buy something you pay a little bit
extra that extra percentage does not go
to the retailer or whoever's providing
the service it would go to the
government they're things like property
tax especially the local level where if
you own property every year that
property generally is assessed what the
value is and you have to pay a
percentage of that value to
traditionally the local government on an
annual basis and then when you go to the
state and the federal level probably the
most significant tax in fact the most
significant tax is income tax which is a
tax on people's income
now income tax you can broadly view it
as a tax on a percentage of your income
and it can be significant depending on
how much money you make it's not
it's not
uncommon for between state and federal
taxes for people to and things like
Social Security tax etc for 20 30 40 or
more of someone's income to go to these
Collective income taxes so it is a
significant part of folks income so it's
definitely something that you should pay
attention to now I mentioned generally
speaking it's a percentage and that
percentage generally speaking is going
to get larger and larger the more that
you earn and that's an important point
that it's not just a flat percentage
which you still would pay more if you
make more but the actual percentage goes
up now I go into details in other videos
another misconception is is that as you
go into brackets the higher and higher
tax brackets as you make more and more
and as that percentage for those
incremental brackets go higher and
higher that you pay that percentage on
all of your income that's not the case
you just pay that higher percentage on
the incremental income between that
threshold and the next threshold and
then the threshold above that you pay
another higher percentage I know that
can be a little confusing we have some
other videos that break it down a little
bit more in a little bit more detail but
the important thing to realize is as you
make money you're going to depending if
you especially if you reach some minimum
thresholds you're going to give spend a
significant amount of money on taxes the
average American household spends ten
thousand dollars on taxes and if you
make more than average it can be
substantially more than that so this is
just the intro primer I encourage you to
watch the other videos that teach you
how to break down taxes a little bit but
it's very important to think about